>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THIS WEEK WE ARE
AIRING SPECIAL REPORTS ON TECH
TYRANNY HOW BIG TECH COMPANIES
ARE GETTING MORE AND MORE POWERS
AND ENDANGERING THINGS WE THINK
ARE IMPORTANT LIKE DEMOCRACY AND
CLEAR THINKING.
CHINA'S MILTARY IS OBSESSED WITH
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
TRYING TO DEVELOP AN ADVANTAGE
OVER OUR MILITARY.
ERIC SCHMIDT CHAIRS THE PARENT
COUPLE OF GOOGLE.
HE ADMITS CHINA WILL BE THE
LEADER IN AI, AND USE IT FOR
MILITARY OPERATIONS.
NOW GOOGLE IS EXPANDING THEIR
AI.
PAUL JOIN US.
GIVE US THE OVERVIEW OF THIS.
DID I CHARACTERIZE IT FAIRLY?
>> LOOK, IT'S NOT SURPRISING
THAT GOOGLE IS LOOKINGING TO
MAKE RESEARCH INVESTMENT IN
CHINA.
THEY HAVE TOP TIER TALENT AND
ACCESS TO A LOT OF DATA.
CHINE WILL HAVE 20% OF THE
WORLD'S DATA BY 2020.
DATA IS THE FUEL THAT POWERS
LEARNING.
GOOGLE WANTS ACCESS TO THAT
DATA.
IT'S CONCERNING FOR THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Tucker: WHAT I AM CONFUSED
BY.
GOOGLE DESCRIBES ITSELF AS A
MULTI-NATIONAL COMPANY.
BUT IT WAS STARTED HERE.
EVERYTHING ABOUT GOOGLE IS
AMERICAN.
IT WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE TO
START GOOGLE IN CHINA BUT GOOGLE
DOESN'T FEEL ANY OBLIGATION TO
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT OR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> THIS IS CAPITALISM.
>> Tucker: IT'S DISGUSTING.
SHAREHOLDERS AND NOT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF THERE IS A BUSINESS INTEREST
TO MOVE OVERSEAS, THEY WILL DO
THAT.
>> Tucker: AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
SUBSIDIZE THE EDUCATION OF
PEOPLE WHO FOUNDED GOOGLE.
NO OTHER COMPANY LIKE THIS HAS
STARTED IN EUROPE.
SO WE MAKE IT POSSIBLE AND THEY
TURN AROUND AND UNDERMINE THE
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE
COUNTRY.
PEOPLE DESCRIBE THAT AS MARKET
CAPITALISM.
THAT SEEMS IMMORAL TO ME.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY WE ARE
IN A TECHNOLOGY RACE.
IT'S NOT JUST CHINA.
IT'S OTHER COUNTRIES.
VLADIMIR PUTIN SAID WHOEVER
CONTROLS AI WILL LEAD THE WORLD.
FRANCE JUST LAUNCHED THEIR PLAN.
WE HAVE TO COMPETE AND FOUND
COMPANIES AND WIN THIS RACE BY
BEING FASTER THAN OTHERS.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER THING THAT
CONFUSES ME.
MAYBE YOU HAVE THE ANSWER.
COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE ARE BIG ON
IMPORTING TALENTS AND ARGUE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH ENGINEERS.
IS THERE ANY THOUGHT BY THE BILL
IS THERE ANY THOUGHT BY THE BI L
BILLONAIRS WHO RUN THESE
COMPANIES TO INVEST IN AMERICAN
EDUCATION?
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT PRODUCING
SCIENTISTS, BUT BECAUSE THEY
FEEL OBLIGATED TO THE
SHAREHOLDERS THEY DON'T FEEL
THAT?
>> SOME OF THE LEADERS DO.
ERIC SCHMIDT FROM GOOGLE'S
PARENT COMPANY WAS PART OF THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT ADVISORY
BOARD.
HE'S BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN TALKING
TO PEOPLE AT THE PENTAGON ABOUT
HOW THE UNITED STATES CAN RETAIN
ITS LEADERSHIP IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
>> Tucker: REALLY.
ANDY PUT A LIBRARY IN EVERY TOWN
IN AMERICA ONCE HE GOT RICH
HERE.
I DON'T SEE ANY OF THESE GUYS
GIVING BACK.
THEY SEEM TO JUST BE TAKING FROM
IT.
>> I THINK A LOT OF THEM COULD
DO MORE.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.